Older people tend to complain that youngsters are destroying everything they've built,...
...and millennials are responding that they've been dealt a bad hand.
But what are the actual differences between generations?
Is there any truth to their stereotypes?
One big setback that both these generations have been through: The Great Recession.
While it affected both groups, this moment in history occurred...
...when millennials were just entering the workforce.
The young invincibles compared the earnings of boomers and millennials at the same age,...
...adjusted it to 2013 wages and found that millennials earned about $10,000 less annually.
All these changes transformed the way young people lived,...
...their expectations, their workplaces and their homes.
But how do all these changes affect personality and values that define each generation?
There is some truth in stating that values or priorities have shifted.
For example, marriage has gone out of fashion.
Fifty-seven percent of millennials have never been married,...
...and the age that young people get married has shifted by six years during the last 40 years.
Millennials are less religiously affiliated, too,...
...but the most common stereotypical image of a millennial and their values...
...is a mobile memory packed with an infinite number of selfies.
As new technology enters our lives,...
...it's starting to get harder and harder to understand our similarities...
...and you may feel that the gap between generations widens.
But, as always, communication is the key.
Not all baby boomers are lost when it comes to technology,...
...and millennials actually understand English words, not only emojis.